question do you think Chris Brown is a
nice guy or a bad boy
[Applause]
that's nice you don't think like the
tattoos you know he's gotten arrested
before he looks like a bad boy but he's
a little bad little he's got a little
bad in him like he tries to be nice and
that way he's definitely a bad guy I
think he's redeemed himself since
Rihanna like the whole Rihanna situation
but he's a bad boy but he's got a good
heart I
I think he's a nice Dad now
is a bad boy I'll say he's a good guy
you've got to give someone a chance so
you know people learn and grow is Chris
Brown a nice guy or a bad boy um he's a
bad boy he's a bad boy I'm a big Rihanna
fan I think he's a bad boy nasty naughty
he's a nice guy everyone makes mistakes
everybody has those days you would
classify guys with criminal past says
nice guys womanizers I think it depends
you know people in different
circumstances and they have to do
certain things to you know provide or to
survive so I don't think that someone's
passion really determine their future or
to really represent them as a whole
person do you think women like nice guys
or bad boys but yeah I can't leave the
bad boy alone but I need to go for the
good guy bad boys bad boys they're both
they're both I've got a very good nice
guy you don't want to wet back you're a
man that can stand up for himself put
you in your place but also buy you
flowers and be nice I see a bit of both
you think it changes based on their age
I think if they're a bit older then
you're like okay yeah you think that in
your 20s you like nice guys more are bad
boys like when does it switch I would
say bad boys when you're in your 20s a
bad boy will take you to the trap house
and that's your date we prefer Bad Boys
unfortunately mental illness is very
high I so yeah we prefer Bad Boys the
nice boys always come last naturally
gravitate to bad guys so do you think by
that logic that men should then treat
women worse no I'm not going to advise
no men to treat a woman bad I don't know
it's such a vicious cycle like you in
life you always want what you can't have
so we chase the bad boy because we know
we can't have him I mean I can but I
don't know everybody else girls love a
toxic guy like don't get me wrong can we
really blame them for being dogs I don't
I don't blame them like boys you do your
thing no they shouldn't but I think
people don't like people being too nice
yeah it's just being too nice play the
game but not too much
they're honest though they're honest do
you think the fact that 15 000 women
came to see Chris Brown tonight speaks
to the fact that women tend to prefer
Bad Boys uh no I just think we're all
Millennials and we just haven't seen him
for years so we're just happy to see him
tonight no well yeah it kind of does but
at the same time
I don't know I just feel like I mean if
everyone's choice is to go see who they
want to see at the end of the day like I
know he done some domestic abuse in the
past well it's us who are getting the
tickets that's the thing
[Music]
sort of way
yeah when do you think women like nice
guys and when do they like bad boys what
ages I think that in 20s they like bad
boys but after that they might turn they
switch to the nice guys do you think we
always prefer a bad voice or do you
think that switches with age yeah what
age does that switch 26 my age right now
I want a good boy
what age do women switch to dating nice
boys maybe 20 27. maybe I was going to
say 40. do you guys prefer to date
traditionally or in a more modern
relationship traditionally
just classify yourselves as traditional
women yes I would how so are you a
virgin
I think that's a bit too personal but do
you know what I would have really love
to give you the the most wholesome and
honest answer by being the world is so
judgmental that you know you could say
your truth but you'll still be
stigmatized or you know oh yes you're
not telling the truth so I got kicked
off so I couldn't tell you but listen
there was a lot of us there there was a
lot of us there I got told to leave but
do you guys have boyfriends yes I do I
have a fiance yeah in the past I do yeah
yeah yeah no so if you guys had Chris
Brown offer to fly you out hell yeah
with a boyfriend with a boyfriend would
you go healthy yeah I said if you had a
boyfriend sure it's not these days it's
the boys ain't loyal and that's on that
but boys exactly exactly it's just
admitted
Chris Brown you know because I'm loyal
do you think most women would go yeah
100 who wouldn't I would love to
we'd go but we wouldn't we wouldn't
sleep with them I don't
I take Chris Brown messaged her and
asked the flyer out for the weekend
could she go even my wife I'm like yeah
boy would you go yes yes yes yes yes yes
I mean like I'm going hon I'll bring a
stomach back I'll bring some memorabilia
yeah I'd be the supportive boyfriend he
would let me go yeah he's a supportive
oh come on
if Rihanna wanted to fly your boat go
yes go yes you knew it was like like
she's walking if one of us is gonna
everybody
a lifetime opportunity
[Music]
it's Rihanna and Chris Brown sorry ain't
Tiffany from next door like gone go and
let the win even even if you knew he
wanted to sleep with you listen I might
fall asleep before him
okay with him doing the same thing for
say Rihanna listen Rihanna Fly me out
I'm more lit yes yes absolutely and my
fiance would absolutely encourage it
don't give a I'm going it's gonna
let Chris Brown steal his girl yeah
Independent Women absolutely we do what
we like are you going
but you had a husband are you going
what's wrong
I'm going home I'm going I've had this
conversation and I would it's brought me
back to sleep this is a more loyal men
or women women you all wanted to go out
to the Chris Brown no way no but no but
for you but when it comes to Chris Brown
would you go who's my boyfriend I don't
have that what's that I don't know
what's that what's the boyfriend who do
you think is more loyal men or women
absolutely women if you had a boyfriend
and Chris Brown messaged you asking to
fly you out would you go uh yeah my
boyfriend will have to understand would
you understand if a girl flew him out
like Rihanna flew him out uh yeah I
guess so like all for the cause but
we're not loyal
through LA on an airplane with Chris
Brown we're not loyal
Jose
women have said yes to that I've loved
him since she was a baby I was mother
daughter oh that's so cute if you had a
girlfriend and Brianna offered to fly
you out for a weekend are you going Ren
is flying me out you had a girlfriend
yeah Rihanna's flying you out for a
weekend no bro I mean Barbados trust me
wherever she's at I'll be there no bro
to be honest it's like it's not my
position to be flown out and you have a
boyfriend no if you did and Chris Brown
offered to fly you out for a weekend
you're gone do not disturb
that I'm watching all night right all
the women say they're gone so then how
are women loyal if it was Beyonce the
man would do the same thing are you guys
gonna go
if he's just hanging out yeah it'd be
fun I think he just wants to hang out if
he's gonna fly what do you say like
answering your questions specifically
then yeah okay okay let's say it's
insinuated that he wants something from
you no no no it's too old no are you
going no no finally and now I can't
believe we're in the first nose do you
think the type of guys that women go for
changes as they get older yes yeah
anymore like Mr Nice Guy as you get
older now I'm with someone who's more
um about their business mind you know
the way their family looks things like
that then just looks you are more about
looks when you were younger and that was
less about looks more of a young guy I
used to go for the first one but now
hell no would you say more of like a
provider type guy yes yes for sure would
you agree with that or disagree well
you're only 19. the guy I'm trying to
right now he's quite a bit older and
I've always tried to Old about older
people in the past who my age they were
childish men are childish in the brain I
can't like older guys I'd also treat you
better because it's good looking guy I
was talking to you about three years
older than me he's still treating me the
worst I've ever been treating in my life
so do you guys think women like nice
guys or bad boys bad boys
lame men for treating women like if
that's what we like I feel like you
don't want a bad boy to settle down if
you like it for for the fun again yeah
but then when it comes to settling down
and being with someone long time you
don't want someone like that what age
would you guys want to settle down 28 29
I think the best age to settle down
would probably be like
27. yeah I feel like living your life a
little bit who gets away with cheating
more men or women men no women women who
lies more men or women men men I mean
women are better Liars but I think it's
men that lie more as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible